what's wrong with being colorful
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so I touched on the new
paradigm Daleks when I did my review of
victory of the Daleks not too long ago
but yeah I kinda want to dig into it a
bit more so we're gonna do this as
another Doctor Who dangling plot thread
because I do think they count as that at
this point because aside from the
supreme Dalek and in the backgrounds of
some later episodes we effectively never
saw these things again
they had their introduction a buildup
they kind of won their first he hunted
with the doctor and then nothing the
reason for this has nothing to do with
the actual narrative because it has
everything to do with the fact that the
reaction to the new paradigm Daleks was
not great people had numerous reasons
they didn't like these some people
flat-out just didn't like the design
they were a little bit bulkier people
thought they just looked like they had a
hunchback and didn't love that some
people really didn't like the color
scheme some people didn't mind the
Cosima but thought it was too bright I
didn't mind the brightness in terms of
their introduction because they are
literally like brand-new off the factory
floor Daleks at that point like I would
think that if they had come back more
they would look a little bit more
scuffed up a little more wear and tear
but yeah they are a little bit bright so
some people got turned off by that I
mentioned in my review of victory of the
Daleks that I think a lot of people just
took badly to the fact that they showed
up and immediately blew up the Daleks
that we'd had for about six years up to
that point now narrative Lee it makes
all the sense in the world that the new
paradigm Daleks would have done that to
the old Daleks because Daleks are all
about purity if the new paradigm Daleks
consider themselves to be superior why
would they keep these other dogs around
they would blow them up makes sense
except that people weren't mad at them
blowing up the old Daleks because it did
makes sense they were mad at them
blowing up the old Daleks because it
felt like transformers the movie or
Jurassic Park 3 where they take the
thing that the fans already loved and
then kill it and then try and get them
to love the thing that's here to replace
it instead and that almost never works I
mean you know when the Transformers the
movie happened people didn't fall in
love with Rodimus Prime know they
demanded the return of Optimus Prime
well Jurassic Park 3 came along the
spinosaurus did not become everyone's
new favorite over the tyrannosaurus rex
and yet they try this and they keep
trying it and it doesn't work as an
approach now again as i mentioned in
that review before the idea behind the
new paradigm Daleks is very sobbed but
like that sort of way of introducing
something like oh well this is kind of
like this thing they already like okay
cool we'll kill the thing they already
like so now they just have this they
will love it no they won't so again I do
get the various reasons that people did
not like the new paradigm Dalek some
reacted badly to them I do think that
Moffat just kind of gave up I mean I
here's what I'll say if he didn't have a
really solid plan in terms of what will
be done narrative Lee with them and all
the new paradigm Daleks world was just a
chance to revamp them and put his own
eras visual stamp on the monster well if
that's all he ever planned which I don't
know either way then maybe he was right
to abandon it because of the entire idea
behind the new paradigm Daleks was just
to throw on a new coat of paint and
nobody likes the new coat of paint well
heck with it go back to the old coat of
paint but regardless of whether or not
he had ideas for other stuff I think
there was a lot of potential in this
idea in this concept and the whole
notion of the new paradigm Daleks for
multiple reasons so first off I've said
before that I feel like the whole notion
of different factions of Daleks in
fighting among the Daleks is something I
would really like to see get
reintroduced like fully into knew who it
was an element of classic who after a
while I think probably most prominently
in resurrection and of the Daleks I
think he came up in remembrance a bit as
well because there was this notion of
their the quote-unquote renegade Daleks
and the imperial Daleks those who were
following you know who were you know
following the what they had been doing
and program doing then those who were
following Davros who was still around
and they were fighting with each other
arguing over who was superior blowing
each other up in addition to blowing up
whatever happened to be around because
that's what Daleks do I want that I
would love to see that kind of
infighting come in again and the new
paradigm dogs are literally a perfect
way to do that because they are a
reinvention and while the Daleks that
did in fact bring them about were
prepared to lay down their lives and
believe that the new paradigm Daleks
were superior that's not a reason to
believe that all other Dalek forces
would believe that and that all of them
would just kowtow or bow down or start
listening or allow themselves to be
destroyed by you know the these these
skittle candy-colored new Daleks so
that's one reason that I think it would
have been cool to keep them running it's
not the only one I really like the idea
of having the Daleks have a visual
distinction that goes with a difference
in functionality that's another thing we
haven't really seen since the classic
era really all we've gotten is we've
gotten the Emperor Dalek we've gotten
the supreme Dalek and then everything
else you know as the air has gone on
they brought back some of the old
designs basically as visual Easter eggs
and shoutouts to the past but they don't
they're not different they're just
Daleks again and there isn't a lot of
distinction aside from whoever's leading
them whoever the supreme is
or in in case of series 1 the Emperor
but you go back to again classic error
and you get things like the special
weapons Dalek which yes I know did make
it like a little appearance an asylum of
the Daleks but like the idea of specific
Daleks having specific utility and not
just because some have different
weaponry like I love the idea of a
scientist a strategist a drone I still
want to know what the eternal does I
really that's just gonna bug me forever
the fact that we never got to find out
what an eternal Dalek is but think about
how cool it would be whether it was by
this color coding or just some other
clear visual distinction imagine the
doctor coming across some Daleks and
he's not entirely sure what they're up
to but then a scientist I like comes
through it's like oh that's what I'm
dealing with they're experimenting
they're building they're making new
weapons they're there that's why they're
not killing these these these things
they appear to be taking hostages it's
not hostages this experimentation and
you could get all that just by a
scientist Dalek who strategist I like oh
my gosh is the supreme you could build a
specific mystique around the different
color coding a different visualization
and really just evoke a slightly
different feel over just who the Daleks
again you can get something more
specific because the Daleks do not
always have to be just here's the big
force of them wiping everybody out which
is another thing I've kind of complained
about a bit in modern era Doctor Who
classic era we saw the Daleks in
different modes we got them more
scheming we would get them trying to be
clever and we've had moments of that in
new who actually victory the Daleks kind
of does a little bit um the Daleks in
Manhattan tried to do that a little bit
but by and large the Dalek default in
modern era Doctor Who is just big army
of Daleks until we blow them all up it
doesn't shake up the formula very much
or very often and I think that
certain Daleks that again clearly
visually distinct from each other behave
in different ways would allow us to have
more flexibility in the way they get
used now that's not to say like your
recharacterized the Daleks no you just
have them do the kind of stuff that
works always do but it doesn't always
have to be charged in and exterminate
everybody have the strategist behave
differently from the scientist from the
drone from the eternal from the supreme
like give us a sense that you know they
always have the same goal but some of
them approach things different ways and
if they're working together oh now we're
really in trouble that is the kind of
thing that I think is a lot of the
potential behind the idea of the new
paradigm Daleks this why I say the whole
idea has a lot of potential and as much
as victory of the Daleks was not a
completely successful story on multiple
levels which I talked about in the
review it really does bother me and it's
always gonna bother me that you know the
baby got thrown out with the bathwater
that this idea because the episode they
appeared in was not especially well
regarded and people kind of mocked them
a bit for the for the look that the idea
just got thrown out and again maybe
there wasn't a big idea behind it beyond
just redecorating them but if that's the
case then they really didn't realize
what it was they setup and what they
were working with and what they could
have had and instead they just went oh
well people didn't like it forget it
like wow you really could have gone
somewhere with this a bit it just I just
don't say a bit more than you did like
anywhere like effectively nothing was
ever done with these things like I said
they have technically some of them
appeared since victory of the Daleks but
really they've done nothing ever and I
consider that to be a massive dangling
plot thread and a real real shame
because I would like to see the Daleks
become more dynamic again because they
the show doesn't seem to know what to do
with them more often than not I would
say really since well honestly since
series 5 the Daleks
just kind of been there when a force of
of opponents has been needed or to
facilitate a Davros story they haven't
had really their own proper story very
often like maybe into the Dalek but that
felt more like trying to rebuild Dalek
Caan than its own thing in its own right
I don't know resolution had some promise
so we'll see where things go from there
but I worry about the Daleks stagnating
and it annoys me that one of the big
ideas to inject some new notions into it
and that could have led to a whole bunch
of new style stories was abandoned so
quickly the new paradigm Daleks dangling
plot thread probably never going to get
picked up and I think that's a shame
what do you think about these things
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it if you wish to support
this channel I do have a patreon even a
dollar a month is a help it helps me
cover my bills and make this channel
what it is and hopefully even bigger and
better if you're not in a position to be
able to do that the like button the
SUBSCRIBE they both help
I appreciate it shared this around that
sort of stuff always is a help and of
course as I said comment love that as
well and there's other links besides
there's a link to the book I wrote my
social medias you know my Pio Box
address is down there look at stuff
click on it or don't you don't have to
because at the end of the day you are
the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]